joining me now is former acting ice
director and fox news contributor tom
homan and texas congressman troy nails
tom uh you heard what that the attorney
general moody just said and then the
white house told fox's own peter ducey
that illegals aren't just walking across
the border uh tell us about the reality
about what's really going on there
the reality is that biden's border
policies are killing people at record
numbers and i just heard the a.g she
sounded upset she should be i seen
chadwick fairly said he was hot and
bothered he should be he should be angry
but i wake up i wake up every day
jason pissed off because i've served
this country i wore that green uniform i
was a special agent for decades i've
investigated these organizations as
smuggling trafficking women children
that smuggled drugs smuggled guns i've
held dying children in my hand in my
arms
i've talked to when uh girls as as young
as 11 years old they got raped multiple
times what no one's talking about what
we're talking about here on this show
tonight there's a number of migrants
that have died since joe biden became
president over 1200 migrants have died
1200 deaths on u.s soil since joe biden
became president over a hundred thousand
americans dying of fentanyl overdoses
this is tragic this is this it gets me
angry every day because when you've seen
what i've seen in 35 years you
understand secure borders save lives and
for them to attack me and the trump
administration policies inhumane well we
had illegal immigration on a 40-year low
it was down 83 percent how many women
weren't being raped how many people
didn't die of drug overdoses because the
drugs weren't thrown across the board
like they are now how many migrants
didn't die how many children didn't
drown in the river so i am angry every
day because this administration opened
the border up is causing massive deaths
and pain to not only americans but
migrants and someone in the white house
should care about that
now congressman uh before your
congressman you were sheriff of fort
bend texas tell us what you are seeing
what you're hearing and what ought to be
done
well jason thank you for having me and
tom thank you for your service to our
country for 35 years doing what you did
at the southern border but see being a
county sheriff for eight years in a
large county in texas serving law
enforcement for 30 years i've seen what
this elimination this uh illegal
immigration and the policies of this
administration has done to the great
state of texas and i i have to
compliment chief ortiz i mean he this
interview the interview took place about
30 days ago he was under oath but he
spoke truth to the american people you
could see during the interview he was
you know rubbing his forehead a little
bit he knew that he was giving answers
truthful answers and his boss isn't
going to appreciate it but i'm sure that
chief ortiz went home with a clear
conscience and slept like a baby his
boss hasn't been able to do that for 18
months because my orcas is nothing but a
liar he looks at the camera and tells
the american people the southern border
is closed it's not closed he's a liar
and we need to get him out of there
yeah i i gotta tell you you know for the
white house spokesperson to say people
aren't just walking across the border uh
is totally naive and it happens when you
have a president and a vice president
who are leading this effort and really
truly don't care about this at all
gentlemen i thank you so much for
joining us this immigration problem is
not going to go away unless uh you
congressman continue to pound on the
table and expose the reality of it and
thank you both for your law enforcement
careers and what you've done to protect
the united states thank you